Abbiamo tutti bisogno di poter comunicare informazioni private senza il timore che qualcuno ci ascolti. Ma progettare un
sistema infallibile per farlo non è facile. Nell'episodio di oggi di Qiskit in the Classroom, parleremo di come
qualcosa chiamato distribuzione quantistica delle chiavi possa
essere d'aiuto. Bentornato a Qiskit in the Classroom. In questa serie tratteremo argomenti che potresti incontrare in un corso universitario
legato al calcolo quantistico. Ogni video è corredato da un modulo interattivo collegato nella descrizione, quindi
assicurati di darci un'occhiata. Oggi ci avventureremo nel regno della crittografia quantistica. La crittografia è lo studio
delle tecniche di comunicazione sicura. Questo è incredibilmente importante per molti aspetti della nostra vita. Ogni volta che usi una
password per accedere a un sito web, invii un pagamento digitale, o quando i governi trasmettono informazioni militari riservate, tutto viene fatto
attraverso qualche protocollo crittografico in modo che un intercettatore non possa scoprire i nostri segreti. Ma c'è una tensione qui. Come
possiamo garantire che la persona con cui vogliamo comunicare possa capire il nostro messaggio, ma nessun altro?
Storicamente, i crittografi hanno escogitato molti protocolli diversi per cercare di rendere i loro messaggi il più possibile immuni
dagli intercettatori. A volte le due parti che vogliono comunicare in modo sicuro si accordano su un certo
codice in anticipo, che si spera sia così complicato che un intercettatore non riuscirebbe a decifrarlo. Ma come
persone come Alan Turing e altri decifratori di codici in tempo di guerra ci hanno mostrato, anche i codici più complicati possono essere
decifrati. Idealmente, vorremmo inviare messaggi cifrati in modo tale che non ci sia assolutamente nessuno schema
e nessun modo che un intercettatore possa capire senza avere anche una chiave casuale segreta che solo il mittente e il
destinatario conoscono. Ma allora ci esponiamo a una nuova vulnerabilità. Come possiamo inviare questa chiave e essere sicuri che
nessuno la intercetti? Nel 1984, Charles Bennett e Gilles Brassard escogitarono un
metodo per inviare in modo sicuro una chiave con bit quantistici, ora chiamato BB84. La caratteristica fondamentale di questi bit quantistici
o qubit che abilita questo protocollo è che obbediscono al principio di indeterminazione. Non puoi misurare
un sistema quantistico senza perturbarlo. Oggi inizieremo con un esempio di un semplice codice crittografico. Poi ti
mostrerò come la distribuzione quantistica delle chiavi e il principio di indeterminazione ci permettono di usare cifrature quasi inviolabili.
Ti guiderò passo passo nel protocollo BB84 e infine lo eseguiremo su un vero computer quantistico.
Prima di tutto, iniziamo con un gioco che potresti aver visto chiamato crittogramma.
Ti viene data una sequenza di lettere apparentemente casuali, ma usando la tua conoscenza degli schemi della lingua inglese
puoi sostituire una lettera con un'altra per dare senso al messaggio. Ecco un esempio. Questo è un
messaggio segreto con un semplice cifrario a sostituzione. Quindi tutte le R rappresentano una lettera, le M rappresentano
un'altra, e così via. Se vuoi provare a risolverlo da solo, metti in pausa il video adesso.
Si scopre che questo messaggio è stato cifrato usando un cifrario molto semplice chiamato cifrario di Cesare, in cui
l'alfabeto è semplicemente spostato di un certo numero, in questo caso 9. Quindi A diventa J, B
diventa K, C diventa L e così via. Più lungo è il messaggio, più è facile
vedere lo schema. Quindi, con un messaggio lungo come quello che ci è stato dato, il cifrario di Cesare o qualsiasi altro cifrario che semplicemente
sostituisce una lettera dell'alfabeto con un'altra è piuttosto semplice da decifrare. Un modo più sicuro per codificare un messaggio segreto
è con il cosiddetto one-time pad. Con un one-time pad, puoi avere uno spostamento diverso per ogni lettera del
messaggio. Devi solo dire al tuo amico qual era lo spostamento per ognuna in modo che possa decodificare il messaggio.
Questo elenco di spostamenti è chiamato la chiave o il pad. Si chiama one-time pad perché viene usato una volta e poi scartato.
Se viene usato più di una volta, emergeranno degli schemi che potrebbero rendere la cifratura decifrabile. Con la cifratura
one-time pad, sia il messaggio cifrato che la chiave singolarmente sono solo una stringa casuale di caratteri senza senso. Ma
quando li metti insieme, vedi un messaggio segreto emergere dal rumore.
Facciamo un breve esempio. Diciamo che ho già creato e inviato al mio amico questo one-time pad, che di solito è scritto in
binario. E poi voglio inviare il messaggio "I love quantum". Allora codificherei il messaggio
usando il one-time pad in questo modo. Prima convertiamo le lettere del nostro messaggio in binario. Ogni lettera da A a Z
corrisponde ai numeri da 1 a 26 scritti in binario. Quindi A sarà 0 0
0 1, B 0 0 1
0, C 0 0 1 1 e così
via. E poi uno spazio sarà semplicemente tutti zeri.
Questo è quindi ciò che diventa il messaggio. Codifichiamo il messaggio eseguendo uno XOR tra ogni bit del messaggio e il
bit corrispondente nel one-time pad. Se non hai mai visto XOR prima, sta
per "exclusive or", OR esclusivo. Lo XOR tra due bit sarà uno se solo uno
dei bit è uno e zero se sono entrambi zero o entrambi uno. Quindi il primo gruppo di cinque bit nel messaggio codificato
diventa 1 0
0 1 1. Lascio il resto degli XOR da fare per conto tuo. Ma il punto è
che questo messaggio ora è solo una stringa casuale di zero e uno senza alcuno schema. È completamente incomprensibile per chiunque
non abbia il one-time pad che abbiamo usato per cifrare il messaggio. Quindi, cosa abbiamo imparato finora? Alcuni schemi di cifratura
sono migliori di altri, e alcuni possono essere dedotti da una persona intelligente che cerca degli schemi nel messaggio cifrato.
Ma una chiave veramente casuale che sposta ogni lettera di un messaggio segreto di una quantità casuale diversa non può essere
dedotta perché nel messaggio non ci sono schemi. L'unica vulnerabilità in uno schema come questo è assicurarsi che la chiave
usata per cifrare il messaggio non finisca nelle mani sbagliate. È qui che entra in gioco la distribuzione quantistica delle chiavi.
Usando i qubit, Bennett e Brassard hanno trovato un modo per consentire a due parti di concordare una chiave ed essere
ragionevolmente certi che una terza parte non stesse ascoltando di nascosto. Questo protocollo BB84 è un po' complicato, ma
lo percorreremo passo dopo passo. Per questa spiegazione, facciamo tornare i nostri vecchi amici Alice e
Bob. Il protocollo inizia con Alice che prepara un insieme di qubit da inviare a Bob. Questi qubit contengono le
informazioni che diventeranno il loro one-time pad condiviso, ovvero la chiave. Alice genera prima due sequenze casuali della
stessa lunghezza. Una è una sequenza casuale di zero e uno e l'altra è una sequenza casuale di X e Z che rappresentano la
base in cui preparerà i suoi qubit. Poi preparerà ogni qubit in uno stato quantistico secondo la
combinazione di base e valore del bit mostrata in questa tabella. Quindi se il bit è zero e la base è Z, preparerà
il qubit nello stato zero. Oppure se il bit è uno e la base è X, lo preparerà nello stato meno. Se
non sei sicuro di cosa siano queste basi e questi stati quantistici, va bene. Il punto principale che devi sapere è che le
misurazioni in ogni base hanno sempre solo due possibili esiti: 0 o 1 per la base Z, e più o meno per la base X.
Se misuri lo stato zero nella base Z, otterrai sempre zero.
Ma se misuri quello stesso stato nella base X, otterrai un risultato casuale, o più o meno, ciascuno con il 50% di
probabilità. Quindi Alice potrebbe preparare una stringa di qubit come questa, dove qui c'è la stringa casuale di
zero e uno e qui c'è la stringa casuale di X e Z. Quindi il primo elemento di ognuna delle sue
due sequenze era 0 e X. Questo significa che preparerà il primo qubit nello stato più e così
via. Una volta preparati tutti i suoi stati qubit, Alice invierà a Bob questi qubit e Bob sceglierà casualmente tra X
e Z come base in cui misurare ciascuno. Aggiungiamo quindi alcune righe alla
tabella per rappresentare le scelte e le misurazioni di Bob. Ecco le misurazioni di Bob
e le sue scelte di base. E qui ci sono i risultati delle sue misurazioni dei qubit che Alice gli ha inviato. Infine, Bob
può convertire ogni misurazione in un bit usando la stessa tabella che Alice ha usato per preparare i suoi qubit. Quando misura lo
stato zero o quello più, assegna il valore del bit zero. E dove misura lo stato uno o quello meno, mette un
uno. Quindi la stringa di bit finale di Bob è questa riga finale.
Nota che quando le basi del passaggio di preparazione di Alice e del passaggio di misurazione di Bob coincidono, anche i loro bit coincideranno.
Ma se Alice sceglie di preparare con Z e Bob misura con X o viceversa,
allora i bit corrispondenti di Alice e Bob non saranno necessariamente gli stessi. Quindi, un modo in cui entrambi possono concordare su una stringa di bit
per il loro one-time pad è chiamarsi al telefono e dirsi reciprocamente quali basi hanno usato per ogni qubit.
Quando le basi coincidono, tengono il bit, e quando non coincidono, lo scartano.
Quindi, in questo caso, Alice e Bob concorderanno entrambi su una stringa di bit 0 0 1 0
0. Come protegge questo schema dagli intercettatori non rilevati? Vediamo cosa succede quando un tale intercettatore
di nome Eve intercetta i qubit che Alice invia a Bob. Non sa in quale stato si trovano questi qubit né come
Alice li ha preparati. Quindi, grazie al principio di indeterminazione e a qualcosa chiamato teorema di non clonazione, non può
semplicemente fare una copia identica dei qubit da passare a Bob. Se potesse, sarebbe in grado di
spiare senza essere rilevata. Invece, indovina una base in cui misurare ogni qubit, li misura, e poi
prepara un nuovo insieme di qubit falsi da inviare a Bob. Ci sono altri modi più subdoli in cui Eve potrebbe provare a
scoprire i qubit, ma nessuno di essi aggira il principio di indeterminazione.
Quindi, assumeremo semplicemente questo metodo diretto di intercettazione da parte di Eve. Ecco una tabella che descrive
la preparazione di Alice, l'intercettazione di Eve e la misurazione finale di Bob. Ora quando
Alice e Bob parlano al telefono per confrontare le loro basi, decideranno di tenere questi bit per la loro chiave, ma i
bit non coincidono. Questo perché Bob stava misurando qubit preparati da Eve, non i qubit originali che aveva Alice.
Se confrontano un sottoinsieme dei bit nelle loro stringhe di bit, vedranno che alcuni non coincidono e
concluderanno che deve esserci stato un intercettatore. Quindi, poiché Eve è stata scoperta, Alice e Bob scarteranno
le loro stringhe di bit e riavvieranno il protocollo dall'inizio. Ma se Eve non avesse intercettato e il sottoinsieme dei
bit che Alice e Bob hanno confrontato fosse coinciso, potrebbero procedere e usare i bit rimanenti che non hanno
confrontato come chiave condivisa. Una volta che Alice e Bob hanno una chiave condivisa, Alice può inviare messaggi cifrati a Bob, e
Bob è l'unico che può decifrarli usando la chiave. Ora che abbiamo esaminato il protocollo, proviamolo su un
computer quantistico. Ci sono un paio di cose da tenere a mente per questo esperimento. Prima di tutto,
BB84 è davvero utile solo se Alice e Bob sono lontani l'uno dall'altro. Per l'esperimento che stiamo per fare, Alice
e Bob si trovano sullo stesso chip quantistico. Quindi, questo esperimento non sarà utile per scambiare informazioni private, ma è
comunque una buona dimostrazione concettuale di BB84.
Secondo, i veri computer quantistici hanno rumore. Quindi, anche se la base di preparazione di Alice coincide con la base di misurazione di Bob
e non c'era nessun intercettatore, c'è comunque una piccola possibilità che misurino bit diversi a causa di errori nel
computer quantistico. Quando confrontano le loro stringhe di bit per verificare la presenza di intercettatori, devono avere una certa tolleranza per gli errori prima di
concludere che un intercettatore deve averli disturbati e scartare l'intera chiave. Ora, con queste
avvertenze, iniziamo con un esperimento senza intercettatore. Prima, generiamo casualmente
tre stringhe di bit diverse, ciascuna con 20 bit. La prima è la stringa di bit iniziale di Alice.
La seconda è un elenco di basi in cui Alice preparerà i suoi qubit.
Qui abbiamo scelto zero per rappresentare la base Z e uno per rappresentare la base X. L'ultimo elenco è le basi in cui
Bob misurerà ogni qubit. Basandoci su quei tre elenchi, possiamo creare un diagramma circuit con le istruzioni per
la preparazione di Alice e le misurazioni di Bob. Tutti i qubit partono nello stato zero. Quindi per preparare i suoi qubit nella
base Z, Alice o non fa niente per lo stato zero, oppure applica un gate NOT o X mostrato come le caselle blu etichettate X
per lo stato uno. Per preparare nella base X, applica un gate Hadamard che porta zero allo stato più,
oppure un gate NOT seguito da un Hadamard per preparare lo stato meno. Poi invia i qubit a Bob. Il gruppo successivo di caselle
nel circuit rappresenta le misurazioni di Bob. Per misurare nella base Z, non ha bisogno di applicare altri gate.
Misura semplicemente, come mostrano queste caselle grigie. Per misurare nella base X, prima applica un Hadamard e
poi misura. Eseguiremo questo circuit usando il primitivo sampler di Qiskit Runtime. E l'output è la stringa di bit delle misurazioni di Bob.
Poi possiamo confrontare le stringhe di bit di Bob con la stringa di bit iniziale di Alice, scartando i bit
in cui le loro basi non coincidevano. E vediamo che entrambi ottengono la stessa chiave.
Ricorda che si tratta di hardware reale, quindi occasionalmente potrebbe esserci un bit che dovrebbe coincidere ma non coincide. In questo caso tutti i
bit coincidono, ma se lo esegui di nuovo da solo potresti avere un errore, ma finché la fedeltà è vicina a uno
Alice e Bob possono essere ragionevolmente certi che non ci fosse nessun intercettatore. Ora vediamo cosa succede se Eve intercetta i
qubit. Ora abbiamo due circuit. Il primo mostra la preparazione di Alice e l'intercettazione e la
misurazione di Eve. Il successivo mostra la preparazione dei qubit falsi da parte di Eve e la misurazione di Bob. Possiamo
eseguire questi circuit come prima, poi vedere cosa otterrebbero Alice e Bob quando confrontano le loro stringhe di
bit. Questa volta ottengono una fedeltà di 6 periodico. È molto più bassa di quanto
possa essere spiegato dal rumore del computer quantistico. Quindi concludono che Eve stava spiando. Il calcolo quantistico è
ben noto e spesso sopravvalutato per il suo potenziale di risolvere problemi difficili. Ma la comunicazione e la crittografia quantistica
spesso ricevono molta meno attenzione, anche se il potenziale che il calcolo quantistico può offrire in questi settori è ugualmente
significativo ed entusiasmante. Oggi abbiamo discusso il primo protocollo scoperto per la distribuzione quantistica delle chiavi, che è
praticamente immune all'intercettazione non rilevata. Se vuoi provare a inviare un codice inviolabile con
una chiave certificata quantisticamente, vai al modulo collegato nella descrizione.
Grazie per aver guardato e ci vediamo la prossima volta.